wir machen heute auf mit einer wichtigen
rede des us präsidenten joe biden mit
der rede zur lage der nation natürlich
ging es hier im kern um den ukraine
krieg im kern um vladimir putin das hat
joe biden ihm heute mit auf den weg
gegeben
wir hatten diese rede jetzt ein mit
herbert bauernebel unserem usa
korrespondenten uns jetzt zugeschaltet
guten morgen herr becker ready was
bedeutet das genau für was sind die
amerikaner denn bereit
joe biden hat hier die gunst der stunde
genutzt um eben eine kraftvolle rede zu
halten das war eine wichtige chance für
ihn hier führungsstärke zu zeigen ja hat
ganz klar gesagt dass er versuchen wird
bleibt mir gut in die schranken zu
weisen er sagte auch der kreml des pop
geglaubt da könnte über uns drüber
rollen allerdings der westen wäre bereit
gewesen er wäre wladimir putin hätte
eine wand der stärke als er lebt in der
in der ukraine das alles sehr
martialisch starke worte allerdings
gleichzeitig natürlich rollen die panzer
in der ukraine die russischen panzer und
die kritik an joe biden will trotz
dieser rede nicht verstummen warum denn
die amerikaner nicht mehr getan haben
früher es war allerdings trotzdem ein
signal dass eben der westen zusammen
stehen wird das amerika hier eine
führungsrolle übernehmen möchte zu
beiden hat wie bekannt auch angekündigt
dass nun auch amerika dem beispiel
europas folgen wird den luftraum zu
sperren für russische maschinen
flugzeuge all das wirklich starke worte
ein signal an wladimir putin und dann am
ende der rede sagte joe biden
gogos holt kritik es war etwas kryptisch
eigentlich denn es stand nicht im
redemanuskript und zwar wirklich die
letzten worte diese einstündigen
ansprache und führte auch zu einiger
verwirrung auf twitter und anderen
sozialen medienkanälen denn man wusste
jetzt nicht genau was war gemeint war es
ein allgemeiner aufrufe an der
amerikaner stärke zu zeigen oder war es
ein direkter auswurf premier putin zu
holen lasst es uns angucken herbert
lasst uns das angucken wie joe biden
seine rede beendet hat mit diesem go get
in diesem moment den du gerade
angesprochen hast
ja was spekuliert amerika heute danach
ging er unter applaus davon gaerte
meinte wladimir putin
es war sehr choreografiert diese aussage
es war es offensichtlich nichts
spontanes obwohl es wie ich vorher
gesagt habe nicht im redemanuskript
gestanden ist es scheint so nachdem ein
drittel der ganzen rede wladimir putin
und dem krieg in der ukraine gewidmet
war dass es sich tatsächlich um einen
hinweis einen querverweis auf den
russischen präsidenten handle oder
andere spekulierten dass es hier einfach
nur ein
starkes wort ein anruf zu den
amerikanern gewesen sein könnte hier mut
zu zeigen und mutig in die zukunft zu
gehen es ging ja auch sehr viel um
innenpolitische innenputz joe biden
innenpolitische agenda so gesehen ist es
ein bisschen kryptisch falls er heute
dass hier eine diskussion losgetreten
wird auf social media dann ist es schon
beiden gelungen er blicke auf die starke
momente dieser rede es gab aber auch
eher unsichere momente wie wir sie von
joe biden ja auch in der vergangenheit
bereits erlebt haben auch das werben
des iranischen volkes herd mal lässig
die ukraine mit den iranern verwechselt
herbert ganz so stark war die rede dann
in teilen eben doch nicht
nur beiden ist natürlich auch bekannt
als vertreter in serie und das ist ihm
leider diesmal bei dieser wichtigen rede
auch passiert auch das natürlich hat für
heftigen spott und häme gesorgt
besonders auf viele sagten sie wir sie
wären ja heilfroh dass die iranischen
menschen sich nicht einschüchtern lassen
würden von vladimir problem also sehr
viel spott und hohn im internet und
natürlich schon ein kleines blaues auge
auch für joe biden denn diese rede ist
wie gesagt eine große chance ist nur
einmal im jahr das sind sehr viele
amerikaner zu rund um die welt wird sie
beobachtet und so einen fehler sich zu
leisten ist natürlich schon eine kleine
blamage und da gab es die emotionale
momente in dieser rede wir haben das
gerade gesehen die ukrainische
botschafter wenn dort um abend von
sill beiden von der ehefrau des
us-präsidenten und es gab diesen jungen
es gab joshua der dort war der sich die
rede angeschaut hat vom us präsidenten
das hat jetzt nichts mit der ukraine zu
tun aber er wurde ein bisschen zum star
ist dann in amerika der kleine 13
jährige josua was hat es mit ihm auf
sich ganz kurz herbert
ja der junge habe ein wenig
[Applaus]
der junge hat dem
präsidenten ein wenig die show gestohlen
natürlich es ging darum das ist wie
gesagt joshua 13 jahre alt er leidet an
diabetes und verbrauchen und medikamente
jedes monaten ist und mit medikamente
sind natürlich wahnsinnig teuer und das
war der punkt von joe biden dass er
versuchen möchte eben arzneimittelpreise
für den normalen bürger zu senken durch
dienst mit der pharmaindustrie aber doch
mit wirklich berührender moment den man
hier gesehen hat bei dieses also auch
das gestern passiert in der nacht hier
bei joe biden bei der rede zur lage der
nation des us-präsidenten wird ein 13
jähriger plötzlich zum star zurück zu
dem was wir in der nachgesehen haben mit
blick auf die ukraine danke für den
moment herbert denn diese aussage
beschäftigen uns heute patricia am ende
der rede wir schauen noch mal auf das
wie joe biden da gestern abgetreten ist
mit diesen worten an platinen
die haben es gehört wir schauen mal wie
diese worte so in russland ankommen und
schalten zu unseren kollegen peter
thiede in moskau schönen guten morgen
peter gauguin nimmt man das dort in
moskau vielleicht persönlich
mitnimmst nicht mal war also wir haben
ja fast nur staatliche medien da kommt
so etwas gar nicht an
aber ganz realistisch sieht man den
präsidenten möglicherweise in gefahr in
diesen zeiten also in der ukraine wissen
wir das natürlich selensky ist in
todesangst das hat er auch selber gesagt
aber gibt es auch ähnliches auf
russischer seite möglicherweise
also wir wissen ja dass wladimir putin
ohnehin angst hat also er hat sich ja
schon von corona virus so befürchtet und
fürchtet sich da immer noch dass er seit
zwei jahren im quasi isolationen lebt
wir sehen wir kennen ja dieses absurden
bilder mit diesen langen tischen oder
mit viktor orban mit sekt anstoßen gibt
getrennt von einem kompletten
perserteppich dem viereinhalb meter lang
war und wenn der sport show und angst
hat und wir wissen dass er jetzt
permanent an anderen orten ist immer
verlegt wird von dem fmo dies das ist
sein sicherheitsdienst und bewacht von
daraus garde ja von der national gerade
die er extra geschaffen das sind von ein
paar jahren weil er den anderen
sicherheit zu definieren sich traut aber
realistischerweise gott getty mehr denn
ja ja das ist eine wichtige frage aber
das wollen wir von dir wissen wie ernst
es gibt den russischen geschäftsmann
alex 100 maschinen das ist ein mann der
mal für boris jelzin den wahlkampf
finanziert hat er hat ziemlich viel geld
und er setzt jetzt kopfgeld aus schreibt
hier der kollege anders er schreibt über
diesen geschäftsmann alex von der nie
schien und sagt mensch der setzt jetzt
eine million dollar kopfgeld auf putin
aus was steckt dahinter deiner meinung
nach wie ernst es sowas zu nehmen
das ist erstmal eine psychologische
kriegsführung und die millionen müssten
sich irgendjemand verdient hatte putin
rankommt man kommt momentan einfach
nicht dann werde mir putin dran er lebt
in einem kokon in einem
sicherheitsprogramm im prinzip ab
gepanzerten blase da sind wirklich seine
engsten vertrauten um ihn herum daraus
müssten sich jemand verschwören oder von
den sicherheitskräften müsste sich
jemand verschwören das ist in diesen
russland zu diesem zeitpunkt absolut
unwahrscheinlich wir müssen wir daran
denken selbst josef stalin der die
ehefrau eines engen vertrauten eines kp
führer stadt einsparen lassen der den
großen terror gegen die eigenen leute
eingesetzt hat der sein eigenes kabinett
war sie halbiert hat und umgebracht hat
wo man hinterher denn die fotos
retuschieren musste damit er mit trotzki
und und andere ja nicht mehr drauf sind
selbst der ist nicht umgebracht und dann
hat man dann als ein herzinfarkt quasi
die letzte hilfe verweigert aber selbst
da ist nichts passiert und wir müssen
wir weiter zurück in selbst adolf hitler
ist nicht getötet worden und das lade
mir putin jetzt kurzfristig umgebracht
wird also der satz von joe biden macht
nur dann sinn wenn dahinter noch eine
aktion steht wenn irgendwelche anderen
kanäle offen sind dass die usa einem
anderen aus dem gut ihn zurück und
signalisiert hätten wenn ihr ihn
umbringt oder ihn oder ihn stürzt dann
habt ihr unsere unterstützung dann enden
diese sagen konnte und dann macht das
sinn sonst ist das einfach nur ein
spruch täter gesagt putin lädt der zeit
oder auch schon länger in einer art
kokon also wirklich abgeschnitten und
das gleiche macht er ja auch mit seinem
volk in einem art propaganda kongo ohne
die informationen die objektiven
informationen über das was gerade in der
ukraine passiert wie es überhaupt der
zeit der zugang der russinnen und russen
an informationen
der ist schon immer schwierig weil ich
habs jetzt letzten tage immer schon
gesagt 98 prozent oder mehr der gesamten
medien in diesem land sind entweder
staatlich also verstaatlicht worden den
eigentümern abgefressen oder aber die
mussten zwangsverkauf und dann sind die
eingegliedert worden zum beispiel in den
gastraum konzern gazprom media das ist
einer der grössten für elektronische
medien vor allem auf die regionale und
lokale medien vor allem radiostationen
sind da drin und ja
da kommt fast nur noch propaganda an es
gibt dennoch die nowaja gaseta die
wirklich wacker immer fallen von krieg
statt und auch recherchiert und auch die
bilder hier veröffentlicht aber es ist
kein riesen massenmedium und dann gab es
bis heute muss man sagen welche moskwy
selbst das gehört zum gastraum konzern
moskwy und die tv stationen die auch
berichtet haben und die auch von krieg
gesprochen haben die sind seit heute in
russland nicht mehr zu erreichen die
kann man nicht mehr empfangen in europa
sind sie noch zu empfangen aber hier in
russland nur über vpn also über so eine
geduldete verbindung die sind aber auch
in den meisten in den meisten hotels zum
beispiel gar nicht möglich ist nicht
zugelassen also da ist abgeschaltet
worden und da beginnt jetzt wirklich
auch also selbst im gazprom-konzern wenn
echo moskwy abgeschaltet wird dann ist
es schon echten schritt und dann ist die
lage wirklich ernst und es gibt dann
aber glücklicherweise gegenschläge es
gibt ja gibt anonymus und andere hacker
kollektive die zurückschlagen so sind
heute morgen und seit gestern abend
schon die internetseite der zeitung
kommersant dann der staatlichen medien
rbk und auch von ria wir es wird das
größte was es hier gibt ein staatlicher
nachrichtenagentur und tv sender die
sind nicht erreichbar die sind
abgeschaltet worden sind direkt danke
peter tiede auf die strassen von moskau
also der krieg in der ukraine der auch
zu einem neuen kampf von putin gegen die
sowieso nicht in den ruin russland
herrschende meinungsfreiheit führt danke
peter